he's back
[Music]
as expected although i was starting to
wonder what was going on i did bourbon
yeah urban meyer said saturday we're
gonna convene on sunday staff's gonna
talk about tim tebow what are we gonna
do with tebow monday crickets tuesday
crickets wednesday crickets thursday
morning shafty reports
tim tebow signed his contract with the
jacksonville jaguars he's now a tight
end he's now spot number 90
on the roster i counted them up last
night and i checked it twice they had 89
guys as of last night today they've got
90. they're boasting near perfect
attendance at the off-season program
tebow's gonna be there i still don't
understand two things chris yeah why
wasn't he there on a tryout basis for
rookie mini camp get him out there
against something other than no one
let's see what he looks like running
around on a football field with guys
more than a decade younger than him and
then why wasn't he there from monday
when phase two of the offseason program
began he missed three days of work that
would have been very helpful to a guy
who's trying to compete for a roster
spot then again i don't know how much of
a competition it is i still predict he's
going to have a spot on the practice
squad and he's going to be a guy that
gets called up on game days they're
going to put him in that jersey i did
think i did think
that they were waiting to do something
with gardner minshew so they could give
tebow number 15. they don't have to give
him a number right away yeah
yeah you're right i mean i would think
maybe gardner minshew is in trouble
there to a degree anyways you know they
do have jake luton gluten who played
last year and did a good job too so they
might feel comfortable with him as a
backup i i don't know but you're right
that time could come to where 15 becomes
available
and they do have cj beathard too
so they have wiggle room to get rid of
gardner minchu if there's a team out
there that goes wait we have a good
starter we're a super bowl team we don't
have a good backup gardner minchi is
going to be one of the guys that gets
called if there's a team looking for
that and then 15 is available and now we
start tebow man mania and you know the
khan family makes 97 million dollars on
the first day because the 90th guy on
the roster is wearing 15. so that's how
it'll work
i i've heard all sorts of different
theories and ideas and other cons
pushing this and how much of this is
meyer and look the bottom line is i
gotta think it's mine
urban meyer is the only coach that was
gonna give tim tebow a job that's what
it comes down to we made that argument a
week or two ago or at least i did i
don't know whether you agree with me or
not barbara had become the coach of the
jaguars maybe that's when we would have
seen colin kaepernick get back in
because harbaugh has been the one guy
the one coach who has consistently
praised kaepernick over the last four
years now i don't know maybe khan
wouldn't have gone for it maybe the
local fans would have rebelled but with
tebow it's a no-brainer meyer's the one
guy that would want him the jacksonville
fan base will embrace him they're going
to sell jerseys and tickets even though
there's no guarantee he's going to be in
uniform when the regular season rolls
around and now we move forward and we
see
what he can do what he has there's only
so much of practice that the media is
going to be able to see
and and you know the other question is
what kind of eye rolling are we going to
see in the locker room as as greg
mcelroy pointed out the former jets
backup quarterback who lived through
tebow mania with the jets yeah the
fourth or fifth string tight end gets
all this attention all these interview
requests all this buzz you know espn's
going to descend on that place what a
shock that espn reported this he works
for espn right they're never going to
say anything negative exactly right
listen i can tell you from experience
too the year after i left the denver
broncos they drafted tim tebow he rubbed
a lot of people raw in that locker room
he made himself available as the second
and third string backup a quarterback
to the press every day and had and made
him like that's just kind of a no-no
you're not playing you're not doing
anything
the guy that's starting is the guy
that's there we don't need a narrative
around you who's not doing anything
that it bothered people there then they
had the the billboard up that said start
tim keep over coward and he never made a
comment to say oh no kyle's a starter
nothing nothing nothing so listen ever
since that you know me i was off that
wagon in a hurry and yeah we're gonna
see where this goes this this is to me
crazy but urban meyer is so indebted to
this guy
it's as as much as i've ever seen any
coach with an athlete ever really i
can't really ever remember anything he
does i mean it was like he's my son on
the sidelines back in florida we're
gonna like hug you and we're gonna rub
heads together like you're my little kid
hey percy harvin ran 90 yards aaron
hernandez got a ball down to the one
yard line tebow you run it in and we'll
act like you did the whole drive that's
just the way it's been it's so that's
where uh
it's gonna be dicey in my opinion and
mike you brought up like the rookie mini
camp and missed reps and things like
that to me the thing that jumps out of
my head why they didn't do that
is the very reason you don't really want
to sign him to the team because why what
would have happened if tim tebow was at
rookie minicamp
what would have happened like what do
you think uh
uh trevor lawrence would have thrown him
a pass that bounced off his helmet yeah
well that would have happened but they
then we would have like saw three balls
that he caught and that's all we would
have talked about and then it would have
been sportscenter that's all they show
and it's like oh wait they drafted
trevor lawrence i forgot like damn i
thought tebow was doing everything on
the team and i mean i would think that
would be part of the reason maybe you
didn't see him this weekend so i don't
know well it's this is going to be a
great idea
isn't that isn't that reason enough that
just to say no is it isn't that reason
enough
if you can't bring this guy who you
genuinely believe
let's give urban meyer the benefit of
the dow just for a few minutes he
genuinely believes
that the rest of the league every other
coach that's been in the nfl since 2012
has gotten it wrong
that this is a guy who can contribute
this is a guy who even though he's going
to be 34 i think in august this is a guy
who who can he stays in great shape
awesome shape great ball skills all the
stuff we heard from urban meyer um
yeah what the fact that you would have
to
deny him opportunities to come in
and commence his effort
to prepare to play a position he's never
played before except when the ball
bounced off his helmet
during the 2012 season with the jets you
can't do it because you don't want
him to hijack your rookie mini cam right
and you you don't want
the reporters figuratively brushing by
trevor lawrence the way they literally
brushed by joe montana at media day at
the super bowl
10 years ago in indianapolis i saw it
folks
joe montan is getting pushed out of the
way as
people flocked
to follow tim tebow wherever he went
right it was amazing that's what is
coming into the locker room so
congratulations and condolences all in
one if you're an ardent jaguars fan
because
i don't know how much this helps
but i know how it can it can go wrong
and i don't know why you want to invite
that element
into your locker room i don't know why
you feel compelled to do this
at a time when the focus is
changing the culture turning the page
yeah moving in the right direction with
trevor lawrence right i don't know why
in the hell you would want to undermine
that vibe in any way shape or form with
tim tebow sorry look hey you can
disagree with us all we want but we're
not here to say anything other than what
we believe
and we we established this earlier in
the week yeah it would be a hell of a
lot more fun if chris and i were at odds
like first take on this he takes pro
tibo i take ni tebo and we go make some
good tv by pretending we truly care
about issues we may not truly care about
we both believe this is a mistake we
both believe this is gratuitous we both
believe this is cronyism to the point of
nepotism if meyer views tebow as an
unofficial son that this isn't about
merit this isn't about one of the 200 or
no 90th best 280th
football players in no this is a spot
being given to a guy for reasons other
than merit and uh you can either say it
and believe it you don't have to believe
it we believe it so we're going to say
yeah
that's right i mean yeah we believe it
we follow the league
i mean we've seen things like this
before where it's not necessarily a good
thing for a football team i can speak
from my own experience being in a locker
room or anything like this
yeah like hey
that like you you you laid it out there
you're trying to set a new culture
you're trying to make your mark in the
nfl
like definitely gonna have guys in the
locker room this week now that are gonna
have a little resentment towards urban
meyer and they're gonna be like what the
hell why is this guy here why we why did
he do this and they're gonna make it's
gonna make them think twice about it and
reevaluate urban meyer that's to me the
biggest risk he's taking in this that's
really what it is you're gonna have guys
in this locker room going man what's
this guy all about why is he doing him
favors
and
why is our
locker room or the media session so much
more crazy now and one guy that's not
going to do anything getting all the
attention uh that that creates
resentment there's no other way around
it it's the same thing as like a
quarterback can be resented in the
locker room because he gets too much
attention now think about a guy who's
not the quarterback not very good and
now he's getting all the attention you
know that's gonna just it's gonna piss
off everybody sorry liverpool
and yeah i'm trying to spin this forward
look one of the reasons why teams stayed
away from tim tebow a decade ago was if
you had him on your depth chart as a
quarterback one problem was he was a
crappy practice practice quarterback all
the way back to high school horrible in
practice somehow got it together on game
day i heard stories about when he was at
florida they would be you know thursday
friday of the week before game on
saturday and what in the hell what oh my
god what in the hell are we gonna do and
then on saturday it would all fall
together yeah but he's not gonna help
get your other players ready for a game
he's not gonna be a good scout team
quarterback he's gonna be throwing balls
over the head and
then bouncing them to receivers
throughout the practice week and beyond
that you don't want
to have
this
national group of fans who are
rabid pro tebow
who are blind to realities like
you know he can't throw
he can't play at the level that he needs
to yeah he can somehow pull a rabbit out
of his butt late in the game if the
game's close enough uh but that that's
not enough to sustain a career you're
gonna have those folks saying this guy
should be playing quarterback this
where's the tebow package why isn't
tebow in shotgun that's right we've
we've seen all these other teams have
these packages tim tebow's perfectly
capable to come in and take a shotgun
snap and run it into the end zone and
throw a little pass to a guy running out
to the flat why aren't we doing it we
want tebow we want tebow we want tebow i
i i look i i'm i'm not quite sure
that urban meyer appreciates
the box full of pandora yeah he's about
to open oh man you're right that means
there's all sorts of pandora oh she's in
there lots of everybody is a lot of crap
you're gonna have to deal with it you're
right i mean
i i i'm with you and especially hey in
that part of the country too you know
again it's it's him being unleashed in
in gator territory there sec country
this is not you know the new york jets
or denver that's far away from that so i
would think the fan base and you know
the wanting of him is going to be even
more rabid than we've seen in the other
spots and that to me is scary as well so
we'll see i'm very interested to see how
this plays out what he looks like at the
tight end position i know the jags are
not strong at that position yes but i
don't look at that and go well now
now they're a little better they got
tebow right so uh yeah they're there's
this is gonna be like
soap opera tv here going into the
training camp
and there's now reason for us in the
media to study
every press conference that is conducted
with meyer with trevor lawrence with any
other player who's available to the
media and it's not just read the
transcript it's watch the video yeah
when the tebow question is asked
of everyone the
can they control themselves or is it
going to be
you know or any any tell the scratch of
the face anything because trevor
lawrence i guarantee you has no desire
to talk about tim tebow and anyone else
on the team is going to have no desire
to talk about tim tebow other than maybe
once
but but even then that this is a guy who
last played in the nfl when trevor
lawrence was in middle school for crying
out loud now some of these guys may
idolize him some of these guys may t
maybe tebow maniacs i don't you know i
remember when mike vick was late in his
career one of the concerns about making
him a backup with the team was there
were so many guys in the locker room who
grew up idolizing him that from within
the team they were worried there was
going to be a push vic should be the
quarterback vic should be the
quarterback we want to play with mike
vick right i don't think that same
mentality is going to be in the jaguars
locker room
but regardless it's going to be great
theater i'm not hey look i'm not
complaining oh it's about folks it's
good for business that they did it i
don't think they should have done it
but
from a business standpoint full
transparency i'm glad they did yeah i'm
sure you are i mean and that's i guess
that's why they're doing it to a degree
too
but like you know you kind of said it
about
the fan bases and things like that like
i mean that's what's gonna happen i mean
we've already seen this happen we saw it
the first time around listen i was being
sold the same bull crap
horrible
bullcrap
goods
four years ago with baseball oh
i think he'll make a roster i think he
might get called up oh yeah he's batting
92 is he going to get called up he's
batting
0.092 but you couldn't tell the fan base
that
he's still working on it he might get
called up next year it's the same thing
that's where i want to go it's like oh
okay
you know that's where that's where it
bothers me is just that it's like hey
you failed better job here you go hey
you failed here's a better one and
that's going to rub people wrong in the
locker room too
i i'm not
i'm not
specifically
confident in my recollection of his
baseball statistics i've got them in
front of me now but my general my
general vague sense was
he would hit a home run in his first
at-bat at every level and then strike
out 50 straight times that's kind of
helpful no one and no one paid attention
to the strikeouts now just the fact that
he had a home run in his first at-bat
right whether it was
sub single a single a double a triple a
and they were they were bound to
determine
to get him to the major league roster
and at least
there was
some acknowledgement
stop it that's wrong for the record i
disagree with that
actual footage pete says but uh i you
know i and and people got mad about that
i i it was like this extended tim tebow
fantasy baseball camp that lasted for
multiple years because he sold jerseys
he sold tickets people cared about those
minor league teams
because it was tim tebow yes and uh uh
oh well jaguars hey look
welcome have fun because i know we will
that's all i can say that's all we could
say we'll see where it goes uh it's
crazy crazy set of circumstances there
and a team that i'm excited to see
before all this
now this gets thrown into it you know i
mean talk about a wrench i'm just i want
to see like you said how everybody
handles it the circus around it uh for a
young football team and a new head coach
is certainly not going to make it any
easier
i do want to be fair to tim tebow 2016
with scottsdale he batted 194 below the
mendoza line 2017 with two different
teams he batted 226. 2018 he batted 273.
that's in double a ball okay that's
pretty good triple his triple a
experience in 2019
he batted 163
um so you know
again so so at least it was better than
what i said embellished right at least
he was within range and his total home
runs
were 18
in minor league baseball and strikeouts
347. is that good
i don't think so 47. strikeouts and 18
home runs i don't think so i don't think
that's exactly the balance you're
looking for now it is a strikeout homer
i'm no baseball
but yeah that's not not the one you're
looking for
so
anyway look i
i
we're not trying to
urinate on the guy's dreams
and because that's the argument i get
what's wrong with the guy having a dream
what's wrong with a guy trying to
because this is a zero-sum game you got
90 spots on the roster someone else's
dream necessarily is short-circuited by
this is somebody else out there more
deserving right somebody else who hasn't
had things and i don't want to say
handed to him
i i don't know what else but in the
sports world that's what it is for a
sports version it's handed to him that's
yes that that's the way to say it i
agree with that we're led to believe
it's a meritocracy
and we love the stories of the guys who
against all odds fight and scratch and
claw their way onto a roster there is a
person who is going to lose his ability
to do that because that opportunity to
come in as the 90th guy on the roster
and catch urban meyer's eye and work his
way up the depth chart and maybe
ultimately make it to the roster that's
now gone and that's one of the things i
always say when we get so obsessed with
second chances after the athlete has
fallen from grace due to some misconduct
that he engaged in well you know he's
entitled to a second chance okay fine
but he's taking away someone else's
first chance if you're comfortable with
that if you're comfortable with someone
else on the roster who's never done
anything wrong
being told to pack up his stuff and get
the hell out of here because the guy who
squandered his first opportunity is now
deemed to be worthy of a second one
that's fine but let's call it what it is
let's remember what it is and what it is
in this context is someone being handed
something that someone else deserves if
we're gonna do it based on merit plain
and simple chris well said mike i got i
got nothing else to add to that and i
think you said it and i've said all i
can say without being any more of a jerk
on this subject
all right uh and uh thanks to today's
development we'll have occasions to talk
about tim tebow uh into june and maybe
into august and maybe into september and
maybe beyond we'll see
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports